Witaj ponownie w Quantum Computing in Practice. Jestem twoją prowadzącą Olivia Lanes. Ostatnio przeszliśmy przez przykład
kwantowego podejścia do problemu optymalizacyjnego zwanego Max Cut przy użyciu formułowania QUBO.
Poszliśmy dość głęboko, ale to był tylko jeden przykład jednego podejścia. Dzisiaj omówimy zastosowania w bliskiej przyszłości
szerzej i rozwiniemy naszą intuicję dla różnych typów problemów, dla których spodziewamy się znaleźć przydatne kwantowe rozwiązania,
i zobaczymy kilka ostatnich przykładów ważnych prac wykonanych w naszej społeczności w skali
użytkowej. Wcześniej krótko omawiali, że nie wszystkie problemy wymagają dodatkowej mocy obliczeniowej —
konkretnie informatyki kwantowej — aby rozwiązać je wydajnie. To są problemy, które już najlepiej znasz:
arytmetyka, przewijanie mediów społecznościowych, może gra w Tetris, Doom lub inne gry wideo. Ogólnie uważamy
je za łatwe problemy. Z drugiej strony istnieją bardzo trudne problemy, takie jak znajdowanie czynników pierwszych
ogromnych liczb całkowitych — na tym opiera się szyfrowanie RSA i do rozwiązania którego właśnie Shor's algorithm był zaprojektowany. Innym
przykładem jest znalezienie rozwiązania w nieposortowanym zbiorze danych. Teoretycznie można to rozwiązać za pomocą kwantowego algorytmu zwanego
algorytmem Grovera. Jednak większość ekspertów zgadza się, że te typy algorytmów będą wymagały
implementacji korekcji błędów i technologicznie jeszcze tam nie jesteśmy. Więc idąc naprzód w tej
lekcji i w swojej kwantowej edukacyjnej podróży, pamiętaj, że szukamy tego słodkiego punktu gdzieś tu pośrodku.
To trudny orzech do zgryzienia, ale właśnie to sprawia, że jest tak zabawny. Jedną rzeczą, której jeszcze nie omawialiśmy
za bardzo, jest teoria złożoności obliczeniowej. Jednym z powodów jest to, że może być nieco onieśmielająca — i tak,
złożoność obliczeniowa jest złożona. Teoria złożoności obliczeniowej to dziedzina informatyki, której celem jest klasyfikacja problemów obliczeniowych
według tego, jak trudne są. Jest mnóstwo różnych klas złożoności w klasycznych obliczeniach, ale najbardziej
fundamentalne są: problemy P — to problemy, które można rozwiązać w czasie wielomianowym w skali wzrostu
problemu, co oznacza, że są łatwe do rozwiązania. Następny, trudniejszy typ problemu to problemy NP —
skrót od niedeterministycznych wielomianowych. To problemy, których odpowiedzi można zweryfikować w czasie wielomianowym, ale niekoniecznie
rozwiązać. Dalej mamy NP-zupełne i teraz wchodzimy w naprawdę trudne problemy bez
znanych wielomianowych rozwiązań. Tu mieszkają słynne problemy jak problem komiwojażera czy nawet gra
Sudoku. Gdy informatyka kwantowa zaistniała — przynajmniej teoretycznie — ludzie poświęcili sporo wysiłku na próby
ustalenia, jaką klasę problemów te nowe typy komputerów będą mogły efektywnie rozwiązywać. Nowa klasa
problemów została wynaleziona zwana problemami wielomianowymi z ograniczonym błędem kwantowym, w skrócie BQP. Ich ścisła definicja jest
trochę długa, ale jest to klasa problemów decyzyjnych rozwiązywalnych przez komputer kwantowy w czasie wielomianowym z małym
prawdopodobieństwem błędu. Istnieje szansa błędu, ponieważ pomiar kwantowy jest z natury losowy, ale
prawdopodobieństwo błędu może być dowolnie małe. Teraz wszystkie te klasy żyją w większej klasie, którą nazywamy PSPACE i tu
myślimy, że BQP żyje względem wszystkich innych typów problemów, ale bardzo trudno to definitywnie udowodnić
matematycznie. Zauważysz, że problemy kwantowe BQP niekoniecznie pokrywają się z problemami NP-zupełnymi.
Jednak możliwe, że widziałeś/widziałaś podejścia kwantowe dążące do rozwiązywania problemów NP-zupełnych. Dlaczego tak jest?
Jednym powszechnym błędnym przekonaniem jest to, że nie ma sensu eksplorować rozwiązań
problemów takich jak problem komiwojażera i inne problemy NP-zupełne dla komputera kwantowego lub jakiegokolwiek problemu, dla którego matematyczny dowód
kwantowego przyspieszenia nie został znaleziony. Jednak niekoniecznie tak musi być.
Znalezienie matematycznego dowodu, że algorytm kwantowy jest szybszy niż jego klasyczny odpowiednik, jest rzadkie. Shor i
Grover to dwa z zaledwie kilku przykładów, gdzie to zostało zrobione jak dotąd. Ale to jest w porządku. W rzeczywistości informatycy
wciąż nie byli nawet w stanie udowodnić, że klasy P i NP są różne, chociaż cała intuicja
mówi nam, że muszą być. Porównywanie dwóch algorytmów i tego, jak się skalują, często patrzy na najgorszy scenariusz
dla każdego. Jest całkiem możliwe, że w praktyce najgorszy scenariusz to nie to, co znajdujemy w prawdziwym życiu. Dlatego
nie tracimy otuchy i zamiast tego wprowadzamy ideę rozwiązań heurystycznych. Jeśli jesteś
eksperymentatorem/eksperymentatorką, już znasz i lubisz te typy rozwiązań. Heurystyka to każde podejście do rozwiązywania
problemu, które jest pragmatyczne, ale niekoniecznie optymalne — i to jest świetne, bo rozwiązania niekoniecznie muszą
być optymalne, aby być bardzo użyteczne. Pomyśl na przykład o zastosowaniu finansowym. Nie znaleźliśmy jeszcze
wykładniczego przyspieszenia dla większości finansowych algorytmów, w których mógłby być używany komputer kwantowy. Ale to niekoniecznie ma znaczenie — nie potrzebujemy optymalnego rozwiązania
w finansach, przynajmniej dlatego, że rozwiązanie nawet o 1% bardziej wydajne mogłoby się równać miliardom dolarów
zysku. Jak więc wiemy, jakie przypadki użycia i problemy mogłyby być teraz odpowiednie dla informatyki kwantowej? Mam na myśli, że jest
poważny powód, by wierzyć, że kwantowa użyteczność lub nawet przewaga może być znaleziona albo teraz,
albo w niezbyt odległej przyszłości. Może łatwiej jest najpierw wymienić rzeczy, których problem z pewnością nie powinien mieć. Nie może
wymagać ogromnej liczby qubitów — nie mamy jeszcze procesorów z tysiącami do milionów qubitów. To jeden z głównych powodów,
dla których algorytm Shora i podobne są tak odległe. Circuits też nie mogą być niesamowicie głębokie. Naprawdę trudno mi
powiedzieć dokładnie, jaka głębokość circuit nie zadziała, bo zależy to od tak wielu czynników, ale ogólnie, jeśli twój
eksperyment wymaga głębokości, której jeszcze nie osiągnięto w literaturze, możesz mieć trudny czas. I
wreszcie żaden typ algorytmu, o którym wiemy, że będzie wymagał korekcji błędów, nie może być jeszcze zrealizowany. Jednak szukamy eksperymentów, które
wykorzystują większość dostępnych qubitów na danym QPU. Podkreślaliśmy też
ważność mitygacji błędów i tłumienia błędów, a ostatecznie powinno być oczywiste rozszerzenie do przyszłych
zastosowań, które byłyby ważne dla społeczeństwa i które moglibyśmy kiedyś zobaczyć prowadzące do kwantowej
przewagi. Porozmawiajmy teraz o kilku przykładach przypadków użycia, które wpadają w trzy główne kategorie, które
zidentyfikowaliśmy jako najbardziej prawdopodobne do uzyskania korzystnych wyników w krótkim do
średnioterminowym. Pierwszym obszarem jest symulacja natury. Mówiliśmy o tym wcześniej — jest
tak wiele możliwości dla komputerów kwantowych do ulepszenia badań prowadzonych na poziomie molekularnym i atomowym.
Powodem jest to, że obecne klasyczne metody są ograniczone fundamentalnie nieefektywnymi matematycznymi
opisami struktur atomowych. Przechowywanie i manipulowanie stanem kwantowym wymaga wykładniczej ilości zasobów
na klasycznym komputerze, ale można to robić wydajnie na komputerze kwantowym — i to właśnie sprawia, że symulacja materiałów
i modelowanie chemiczne to jedne z najbardziej obiecujących obszarów zastosowań. Konkretnie mogłoby to prowadzić do
postępów w sekwestracji dwutlenku węgla, alternatywnych bateriach lub wynalezieniu nowych leków. Niektóre
algorytmy szczególnie istotne w tym obszarze to wariacyjny kwantowy solwer własny (VQE), używany do
szacowania pewnych właściwości materiału, takich jak równowaga lub minimalne stany energetyczne. Innym przykładem jest
symulacja dynamiki czasowej (TDS) — ten algorytm służy do szacowania funkcji odpowiedzi lub właściwości spektralnych
materiałów. Chciałam też wspomnieć o nowicjuszu — kwantowej diagonalizacji opartej na próbkowaniu, o której myślimy,
że będziemy słyszeć znacznie więcej w niedalekiej przyszłości. Następny obszar zastosowań to optymalizacja. Optymalizacja jest dość
wszechobecna w obliczeniach, jak możesz sobie wyobrazić, więc przypadki użycia są dość liczne i zróżnicowane.
Niektóre przykłady, o których słyszymy dużo, to optymalizacja portfela w finansach, projektowanie przemysłowe, a także
dystrybucja i łańcuch dostaw. Najczęstszym algorytmem, który prawdopodobnie usłyszysz w związku z optymalizacją, jest ten, który
omówiliśmy już dość szczegółowo — kwantowy algorytm przybliżonej optymalizacji, czyli
QAOA. Na koniec — jeden obszar, który w ostatnich kilku latach wzbudził duże emocje, to kwantowe uczenie maszynowe. Myślę,
że uczciwie powiedzieć, że wygląda na to, że QML nie nastąpi tak szybko jak symulacja we wszystkich prawdopodobieństwach, ale niemniej
są imponujące algorytmy, nad którymi ludzie konsekwentnie pracują, odpowiadające bardzo ważnym przypadkom
użycia. Niektóre z tych możliwych przypadków użycia to przetwarzanie języka naturalnego, analiza ruchu sieciowego, a nawet wykrywanie
oszustw w transakcjach finansowych. Istotne algorytmy w tym obszarze to kwantowa maszyna wektorów nośnych,
kwantowe sieci neuronowe i kwantowe generatywne sieci antagonistyczne. Żeby wyjaśnić: te trzy
grupy, które właśnie opisaliśmy, to szerokie obszary zastosowań. Warto też zaznaczyć, że w społeczności jest
korzyść dla grup pracujących razem, skupionych na konkretnym temacie. IBM zainicjował niedawno inicjatywę zwaną
Grupami Roboczymi, aby pomóc współpracownikom spotykać się i tworzyć produktywną synergię w czterech konkretnych
obszarach: opieka zdrowotna i nauki o życiu, materiały i HPC, fizyka wysokich energii i
optymalizacja. Oto nasze obecne grupy i zaangażowane w nie podmioty. Jeśli chcesz dowiedzieć się więcej o tym, co
Grupy Robocze robią, zamieściliśmy cztery ich białe księgi w opisie poniżej. Jak powiedziałam,
myślę, że najlepszą rzeczą do zrobienia w tym momencie kursu jest spędzenie trochę czasu na eksploracji, na jakich problemach ludzie pracują na
krawędzi tej technologii i rozwijanie naszej intuicji dla wiedzy, jakie typy algorytmów będą działać i jak
je stosować. I zanim zaczniemy, chcę bardzo wyraźnie powiedzieć, że głównym celem tutaj nie jest zrozumienie każdego
szczegółu eksperymentów. Ten typ analizy może być bardzo onieśmielający nawet dla ekspertów, jeśli artykuł jest nieco
poza ich obszarem wiedzy. Celem jest po prostu pomoc w rozwinięciu intuicji dla typów problemów, z którymi komputery kwantowe
dobrze sobie radzą i jak je obsługiwać. A jeśli interesujesz się szczegółami i to wzbudziło pewne
twoje własne pomysły, zdecydowanie zachęcam do przeczytania pełnych artykułów. Konkretne przypadki użycia i
artykuły, na które spojrzymy szczegółowo, to te. Najpierw zbadamy artykuł omawiający
symulację dynamiki hadronów — to należy do kategorii fizyki wysokich energii. Następnie przyjrzymy się problemowi optymalizacji,
konkretnie kwantowej optymalizacji kontradiabatycznej ze stronniczym polem. I na koniec przyjrzymy się kolejnemu
problemowi symulacyjnemu, ale tym razem skupiającemu się na mRNA — kluczowej cząsteczce dla
opracowywania leków i terapii. Jeśli znasz lub nie znasz tych artykułów, to żaden problem — przejdziemy
przez wszystkie trzy. To ważne artykuły, które zajmują się problemami o znacznej skali i pokazują, jak komputery kwantowe
zaczynają być używane jako kolejna metoda badań naukowych. Pierwsza to symulacja dynamiki hadronów
i zagłębimy się w artykuł grupy Martina Savage'a z Uniwersytetu Waszyngtońskiego zatytułowany „Quantum
Simulations of Hadron Dynamics in the Schwinger Model Using 112
Qubits". Jeśli nie jesteś fizykiem wysokich energii, możesz wciąż znać termin hadron — na przykład z
Wielkiego Zderzacza Hadronów (LHC), czyli gigantycznego akceleratora cząstek o obwodzie 27 kilometrów, który umożliwił
ostateczne zaobserwowanie bozonu Higgsa. Hadron to subatomowa cząstka złożona zbudowana z innych małych
cząstek zwanych kwarkami — na przykład neutronów i protonów. Dla kontekstu: LHC zbudowano,
żeby umożliwić badanie fizyki fundamentalnej i tego, co dzieje się z cząstkami, gdy zderzają się przy bardzo wysokich energiach
w tej okrągłej rurze. Dzięki temu naukowcy mają nadzieję dowiedzieć się więcej o tym, jak powstał wczesny Wszechświat
i jak powiedziałam wcześniej, LHC był też używany do znalezienia bozonu Higgsa — ulotnej cząstki odpowiedzialnej za masę
cząstek fundamentalnych. Zasadniczo, interakcje tych cząstek mogłyby być
symulowane od początku do końca za pomocą wystarczająco mocnego komputera kwantowego. Jeszcze tam nie jesteśmy, ale postępy
są robione. Model Schwingera jest prostym modelem używanym do symulowania części tej dynamiki i stał się jednym z
najbardziej popularnych modeli do wyboru. Szczegóły modelu nie są teraz super istotne, ale dla ciekawskich —
jest to model opisujący zachowanie elektronów i pozytonów oddziałujących przez fotony w 1+1D —
co oznacza jeden wymiar przestrzenny i czas. Model ma wiele podobieństw do kwantowej
chromodynamiki, która opisuje, jak kwarki i hadrony oddziałują. Teraz to jest niezwykle trudne do symulowania, więc
model Schwingera jest często używany jako model zabawkowy do badania pewnych zjawisk wspólnych dla
obu. Teraz sposób, w jaki zamierzamy postępować z tym przykładem i resztą wybranych tu przykładów, polega na
zadaniu sobie serii pytań. Pierwsze: dlaczego mieliśmy powody, by wierzyć, że symulowanie tego
na komputerze kwantowym w ogóle zadziała? W tym przypadku elektrony i pozytony w modelu Schwingera mają efekt ekranowania,
powodując wykładniczy zanik korelacji między odległymi fermionami wraz z separacją — co oznacza, że nie ma
aż tak wielu interakcji dalekozasięgowych od qubitu po jednej stronie chipa do innego po drugiej stronie, co jak wiemy
jest bardzo podatne na błędy. To jest naprawdę dobre dla sprzętu, który mamy dzisiaj dostępny. Następne:
czy ten temat w ogóle jest interesujący? Mam nadzieję, że już nieco was przekonałam, że tak — fizyka wysokich energii jest niezmiernie
interesująca. Ludzie byli skłonni wydać miliardy dolarów na zbudowanie LHC i tysiące naukowców i
techników z całego świata poświęciło swoje życie tej dziedzinie — tak ważna jest. Ale
model Schwingera jest uproszczony i nie jest zaprojektowany do obejmowania trzech wymiarów przestrzennych. Niemniej jest to
ważny model, ponieważ wciąż dostarcza aktualnie testowalnych wycinków i użytecznych uproszczeń pełnej
teorii. I na koniec — jak ta praca została wykonana lub jakie podejście by zastosowali, gdyby chcieli kontynuować pracę w
eksperymentach symulacyjnych? VQE jest jednym z najczęstszych podejść i pierwszym krokiem jest prawie zawsze to samo:
przygotowanie stanu podstawowego. W tym przypadku jest to stan próżni i w tym eksperymencie użyli nowej wersji VQE zwanej SC-ADAPT-VQE
do przygotowania zarówno stanu podstawowego, jak i pakietu falowego hadronu na górze próżni. Następnym krokiem jest
pozwolenie hadronom na ewolucję lub propagację w czasie. Na koniec musimy zidentyfikować
obserwable, które chcemy wykryć. Jeśli te kroki brzmiały trochę znajomo — z wyjątkiem części z pakietem falowym hadronu —
to dlatego, że te kroki są bardzo podobne do tego, co omówiliśmy w przykładzie QAOA w poprzednim odcinku.
Mam nadzieję, że zaczynasz dostrzegać tu pewne wzorce. Składniki potrzebne do VQE są bardzo podobne do QAOA —
zaczynamy w znajomym stanie — tutaj w stanie próżni — a następnie pozwalamy mu ewoluować w czasie za pomocą serii wykładnikowanych
Hamiltonianów podzielonych na zarządzalne kawałki, gdzie n jest liczbą podziałów. Jedyną dużą różnicą tutaj
jest to, że tworzymy pakiet falowy hadronu skoncentrowany w naszym circuit, zanim zaczniemy go ewoluować. Jak to
się robi? Stan próżni to stan podstawowy i w zasadzie już omówiliśmy, jak go mapować. Teraz przygotowanie pakietu falowego
hadronu jest nieco inne — na tej próżni hadron może być wzbudzony przez stworzenie pary fermion-antyfermion na
sąsiednich miejscach. Przez przygotowanie superpozycji takich hadronów w różnych miejscach, dowolny pakiet
falowy może być przygotowany. Autorzy wycentrowali swój pakiet falowy w środku circuit, aby obserwować ewolucję
bez przekraczania granicy. Ale pamiętaj — celem gry przy pracy z zaszumionymi QPU jest utrzymanie
głębokości circuit w zarządzalnych granicach. Aby to zrobić, protokół SC-ADAPT-VQE używa symetrii i
hierarchii w skalach długości do wyznaczania niskozbiorowych circuit kwantowych do przygotowania stanu. Idea polega na tym, że
stworzy to ans-atz z mniejszą liczbą parametrów, co odpowiada mniejszej głębokości. Więcej szczegółów można oczywiście
znaleźć w artykule, niż możemy tutaj omówić, więc upewnij się, że go sprawdzisz. Teraz przyjrzyjmy się wynikom. Ten eksperyment był przeprowadzony na
urządzeniu IBM Quantum Heron i zaimplementował kilka różnych typów mitygacji błędów i ich tłumienia,
w tym bardziej nowatorską technikę zwaną renormalizacją dekoherencji operatora, a także dynamiczne sprzęganie,
ekstrapolację do zera szumu i twirling Pauliego. Spróbujmy teraz zinterpretować dane. Obserwabla, którą faktycznie będziemy
mierzyć, aby obserwować propagację pakietu falowego, to coś zwanego kondensatem chiralnym — trochę
abstrakcyjne, ale zasadniczo jest to nadciekła faza hadronów. Możemy teraz zobaczyć pakiet falowy skoncentrowany tutaj na
miejscach wyznaczonych do uruchomienia tego eksperymentu, gdzie kolor odpowiada kondensatowi chiralnemu.
Lewa strona pokazuje wolne od błędów wyniki z symulatora, podczas gdy prawa strona pokazuje wyniki z komputera kwantowego
IBM Torino. Idealne byłoby, gdyby były lustrzanymi odbiciami siebie nawzajem ze względu na symetrię, więc widzisz, że są
pewne niedoskonałości. Ta pionowa oś Y odpowiada kawałkom czasu, które
mierzyłam/mierzyłem wcześniej. Zróbmy więc poziome cięcia przez pierwszy i ostatni krok czasowy danych, aby zobaczyć,
co dzieje się z pakietem falowym. Przy czasie tau równym 1 — tutaj w kolorze pomarańczowym, odpowiadającym
temu cięciu — widzisz, że kondensat chiralny jest wąski i zlokalizowany. Odpowiada to też bardzo dobrze
symulacji przeprowadzonej dla porównania. Przy tau równym 14 jednak jest znacznie bardziej rozszerzone i mniej
zlokalizowane. Może porównanie z symulatorem nie jest już tak doskonałe, ale wciąż możesz wyraźnie zobaczyć bardzo dobrą zgodność między teorią a danymi,
co jest zachęcające. Podsumowując: to jest bardzo fajny przykład typu pracy symulacyjnej, o której możesz początkowo nie pomyśleć,
że można zastosować komputery kwantowe. Jednak faktycznie możesz i działa — nie jest doskonały, ale nie musisz być ekspertem od fizyki
cząstek, żeby zobaczyć, że komputer kwantowy dokładnie przewiduje zewnętrzną propagację pakietu falowego,
co dokładnie tego oczekujemy. Mam nadzieję, że przyszłe prace w tym obszarze będą kontynuowane i fizycy wysokich energii
będą nadal znajdować sposoby na włączenie informatyki kwantowej do swoich przepływów pracy. Celem jest rozwiązywanie problemów teoretycznych precyzyjniej i
tych, których nie można rozwiązać klasycznie, i używanie eksperymentów do akceptowania lub odrzucania teorii w nadziei odkrycia nowej
fizyki, budowania ulepszonych detektorów i prowadzenia do lepszego zrozumienia natury na jej najbardziej fundamentalnym
poziomie. Nasz następny przykład skupia się na optymalizacji i będzie głębokim zanurzeniem w artykuł zatytułowany „Biased Field
Digitized Counter-Adiabatic Quantum Optimization", wykonany przez członków zespołu Kipu Quantum i
Uniwersytetu Kraju Basków w Hiszpanii. Zaczniemy jak poprzednio
z serii definicji. Pierwsza to „counter-adiabatic" — rodzaj ewolucji, który tłumi efekty nieadiabatyczne
doświadczane przez układ, niezależnie od tego, jak szybko te procesy zachodzą. Przypomnij sobie twierdzenie adiabatyczne z
poprzedniego odcinka — zazwyczaj musisz pozwolić układowi ewoluować bardzo powoli, jeśli chcesz, żeby pozostał w stanie podstawowym.
To duży problem, ponieważ im wolniej musimy pozwolić rzeczom ewoluować, tym więcej czasu mamy na powstawanie błędów.
Napędzanie kontradiabatyczne, często skracane jako CD, ma na celu zwalczenie tego przez
dodanie wyrazów, które przeciwdziałają tym niechcianym wzbudzeniom. Główna idea to przyspieszenie całego eksperymentu i
redukcja głębokości circuit kwantowego przez tłumienie wzbudzeń, które mogłyby prowadzić do fałszywych
przejść. Porozmawiajmy teraz o tym, czym jest pole stronnicze. Inne iteracyjne algorytmy, jak VQE, biorą klasyczne parametry do
tych stanów i używają klasycznych optymalizatorów do przeszukiwania wielowymiarowej przestrzeni parametrów w poszukiwaniu zestawu,
który daje minimalne wartości oczekiwane dla stałego Hamiltonianu. W tym przypadku zamiast tego zmieniają Hamiltonian w każdej
iteracji, przechodząc adiabatycznie od znanego przypadku do przypadku zainteresowania. Ale ponieważ nie są przekazywane żadne klasyczne parametry
i nie ma wariacyjnej funkcji falowej, jak aktualizujesz swój stan z jednej iteracji Hamiltonianu do następnej? Otóż
dodają pole stronnicze do Hamiltonianu — jakikolwiek był najniższy stan energetyczny z poprzedniego uruchomienia, dodają wyraz w
Hamiltonianie, żeby faworyzować ten stan. Dlaczego więc ten eksperyment jest
interesujący? Przede wszystkim to nowe podejście, które można stosować bardziej ogólnie do innych problemów optymalizacyjnych.
Ale w tym przypadku zastosowali je do problemu szklanego spinowego Isinga. Jak omawiali wcześniej, wiele kombinatorycznych
problemów optymalizacyjnych można przeformułować jako rozwiązywanie dla stanów niskoenergetycznych Hamiltonianów Isinga. Model
Isinga to seria mikroskopowych spinów rozłożonych na siatce. Model można używać do opisywania szkła spinowego, w którym
namagnesowanie jest nieuporządkowane — zasadniczo małe momenty magnetyczne są losowo zorientowane w siatce. I
dlaczego myśleli, że to zadziała? W zasadzie już nieco omówiliśmy, jak walczymy z dwoma typowymi problemami znajdowanymi w
algorytmach wariacyjnych, gdy omawiali definicje artykułu. Ale podsumowując: proponowany przez nich algorytm
przyspiesza ewolucję, żeby zmniejszyć głębokość circuit, tłumiąc jednocześnie przejścia nieadiabatyczne.
Ponadto nie opiera się na żadnej klasycznej procedurze optymalizacji, co może być problemem prowadzącym do pustych
plateau i utknięcia w lokalnych minimach. I na koniec autorzy upewniają się też, że dostosowują interakcje w Hamiltonianie problemu
do łączności sprzętu w prawdziwym QPU, co jest zawsze bardzo ważne. Na koniec — jak to działa? Jak
powiedziałam, nie używa się tu żadnych klasycznych optymalizatorów, jak to jest często w iteracyjnych algorytmach kwantowych.
Zamiast tego, przez podawanie rozwiązania z każdej iteracji jako wejście dla następnej, algorytm BF-DCQ
stopniowo udoskonala stan podstawowy, przybliżając go coraz bardziej do
ostatecznie ewoluowanego stanu. W połączeniu z protokołami kontradiabatycznymi możemy to robić nawet przy krótko-zbiorowych circuit kwantowych,
które powinny działać sprawnie na zaszumionym sprzęcie. Gdy eksperyment był wykonany, autorzy zdecydowali się uruchomić
algorytm na 127-qubitowym komputerze kwantowym IBM Brisbane. Autorzy pokazali tu
iterację algorytmu optymalizacji dla losowo wygenerowanej instancji szkła spinowego z najbliższymi sąsiadami
powyżej 100 qubitów. Porównują idealne wyniki symulacji dla DCQ i BF-DCQ
a także wynik eksperymentalny i pokazują też wynik klasycznego solvera zwanego Gurobi jako odniesienie. Otóż
przy zaledwie 10 iteracjach BF-DCQ zapewnia drastyczne ulepszenie w porównaniu do
DCQ. Chociaż wynik eksperymentalny jest nieco różny od idealnego wyniku z powodu szumu, wydajność jest wciąż
lepsza niż idealny DCQ. Pokazuje to, że wciąż robi się doskonałe postępy w
kwantowej optymalizacji i dobre wyniki są raportowane dla ponad 100 qubitów po raz pierwszy.
I na koniec — jest bardzo interesujący artykuł eksplorujący przewidywanie struktury mRNA od naszych przyjaciół z
Moderna Pharmaceuticals, zatytułowany „mRNA Secondary Structure Prediction Using Utility Scale Quantum
Computers". Na początek, jeśli jak ja nie brałeś/brałaś kursu biologii od kilku lat, możesz odświeżyć sobie, czym jest
mRNA. Informacyjny RNA to typ RNA zaangażowanego w syntezę białek.
Zasadniczo odczytuje instrukcje podane przez DNA. Struktura drugorzędna mRNA to mniej więcej to, jak łańcuch jest złożony, a
problem przewidywania struktury drugorzędnej RNA to problem znalezienia najbardziej stabilnego fałdowania sekwencji
zasad nukleotydów tworzących DNA i RNA — czyli C, G, U i A. To
zdjęcie pokazuje niektóre z powszechnych struktur fałdowania spotykanych w mRNA. Każde kolorowe wyróżnienie pokazuje
inną strukturę drugorzędną, ale dokładne charakterystyki tego, co sprawia, że jedna z tych struktur jest korzystniejsza od
innej, nie są dobrze rozumiane. Wszystko, co możemy zrobić, to ustalić, która ma najniższą swobodną energię w porównaniu do
stanu niesfałdowanego — i właśnie tutaj komputery kwantowe wkraczają. Dlaczego więc struktury drugorzędne mRNA są
ważne? Ich dokładne przewidywanie jest rzeczywiście kluczowe nie tylko dla rozumienia DNA i naszych genów, ale także
dla projektowania terapeutycznych leków opartych na RNA, jak szczepionka na COVID-19. Jest powód, by wierzyć, że podejście w
tym artykule zadziałałoby, ponieważ od dawna wiadomo, że to jest potężny problem optymalizacyjny dla klasycznych
komputerów ze względu na ogromną liczbę możliwych konfiguracji. I dla niektórych konfiguracji wiadomo, że jest to faktycznie
problem NP-zupełny. Jednak na komputerze kwantowym możemy sformułować przewidywanie struktury drugorzędnej jako
binarny problem optymalizacyjny — coś, z czym wiemy, jak sobie poradzić. Ponadto w literaturze istniały już dowody na
dokładne przewidywanie RNA na małoskalowych urządzeniach kwantowych i symulatorach kwantowych. Więc oczywiste pytanie to:
czy zadziałałoby to na większym sprzęcie? Eksperyment jest przeprowadzany przy użyciu czegoś zwanego wariacyjnym kwantowym solwerem własnym
warunkowej wartości przy ryzyku, który jest modyfikacją tradycyjnego algorytmu VQE i oczekuje się, że
osiągnie lepszą zbieżność. Ten wykres pokazuje rozkład prawdopodobieństw pomiaru
spróbkowanych łańcuchów bitów z odpowiadającymi energiami dla instancji 42
nukleotydów i 80 qubitów. Tutaj łańcuchy bitów symbolizują parowania
nukleotydów. Ilustruje to, że łańcuch bitów o najniższej energii ma wartość energetyczną -140, co odpowiada najniższemu
energetycznemu łańcuchowi bitów znajdowanemu przez porównawczy klasyczny solver — co jest świetne. I jest to optymalna sfałdowana
struktura tego łańcucha nukleotydów na podstawie łańcucha bitów o najniższej energii znalezionego przez sprzęt.
I tym doszliśmy do końca tego odcinka. Moim celem tutaj nie było przytłoczenie cię
szczegółami z różnych artykułów badawczych. Jak powiedziałam, po prostu chciałam dać ci wystarczający kontekst, żebyś rozumiał/rozumiała, jak
wygląda aktualnie praca na krawędzi. Mam nadzieję, że to poruszy pewne koła zębate
w głowach wszystkich i że widząc, jak inni podchodzą do problemów, będziesz mógł/mogła robić połączenia i mieć
odwagę do podejmowania nowych eksperymentów kwantowych, których wcześniej byś nie spróbował/spróbowała. I hej, może niektóre z nich nie
wypalą — i to jest w porządku, bo to jest właśnie badanie. Idąc naprzód, pamiętaj, że typy problemów, którymi jesteśmy
zainteresowani, można grupować według metodologii lub według tematu i wyznaczyliśmy te, które uważamy za
najbardziej obiecujące w krótkim terminie. Pamiętaj, że informatyka kwantowa nie jest dobra do wszystkiego i naprawdę to tylko
świadczy o tym, jak dobrzy staliśmy się w klasycznych obliczeniach. Tylko dlatego, że myślisz, że mógłbyś/mogłabyś zastosować informatykę kwantową
do problemu, nie oznacza, że da to interesujące wyniki. Niestety musisz wziąć pod uwagę skalowanie — głębokość circuit
jest dwusiecznym mieczem. Musi być odpowiednio duża, żeby robić interesującą pracę, której klasyczne
komputery nie mogą wykonać, ale teraz z powodu szumu sprzętu nie możemy pchać jej do ogromnych rozmiarów, bo wierność
się zmniejszy. Chodzi o znalezienie tego słodkiego punktu i wiedzenie, że jest to ruchomy cel. Więc poświęć trochę czasu
między tym a następnym odcinkiem, żeby naprawdę pomyśleć o kilku problemach, które napotkałeś/napotkałaś i o tym, jak mógłbyś/mogłabyś do nich podejść z tym, czego
nauczyliśmy się do tego momentu. Bądź kreatywny/kreatywna i nie ograniczaj się, a jeśli masz jakieś pomysły — nawet jeśli myślisz, że są trochę
szalone — daj mi znać w komentarzach poniżej. Dziękuję za oglądanie i do zobaczenia następnym razem.